l'encré en en vigueur aujourd'hui de la
suspension de la mission de la russie
auprès de l'otan à bruxelles et à moscou
annonce faite le mois dernier par le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov une décision prise en
représailles au retrait de
l'accréditation de huit membres de la
mission russe par l'organisation
atlantique et cela sur fond
d'accusations d'espionnage on va
retrouver tout de suite à moscou notre
correspondante maëlys d'estrées
bonjour maylis comment les relations
entre l'otan et la russie en sont elles
arrivées là
bonjour magali la décision de la russie
de suspendre sa mission et celle de
l'otan fait suite à l'expulsion au début
du mois d'octobre de huit diplomates
russes soupçonnés d'espionnage par
l'organisation militaire à la même date
l'alliance avait annoncé également
qu'elle réduirait les mêmes les
accréditations de la mission russe à
bruxelles de 20 à 10 à partir du 1er
novembre écoutez
les relations entre l'otan et la russie
sont au plus bas depuis la guerre froide
pour nous il ne s'agit pas d'un argument
contre le dialogue il s'agit d'un
argument en faveur du dialogue parce que
c'est justement quand les temps sont
durs quand on fait face aux défis et aux
problèmes comme aujourd'hui que nous
devons nous asseoir autour d'une table
et discuter nous continuerons à oeuvrer
pour maintenir le dialogue avec la
russie y compris au sein du conseil otan
russie et la proposition d'une réunion
dans le cadre du conseil otan russie est
toujours sur la table c'est à la russie
de l'accepter
s'ils dénoncent la contradiction entre
le discours et les actes de l'otan qui
se dit ouverte au dialogue mais entrave
le travail de la mission russe à
bruxelles et ignore depuis plusieurs
années les propositions de pourparlers
émanant de moscou écouter
à partir de 2014 l'otan a réduit au
maximum les contacts avec notre
représentation puis a annoncé l'arrêt
complet de notre coopération au plan
civil et militaire en ce qui concerne la
coopération militaire nous n'avons plus
aucun contact les noyaux washington
lui passe sous 15 au petit comme je lé
déjà précisés l'accès aux sièges de
l'otan a été interdit à nos diplomates
et il est impossible de maintenir les
contacts sans visite quasiment toute la
communication tous les contacts ont été
coupées avec le secrétariat
international de l'otan
ce que l'europe tout cela confirme que
l'otan n'est pas intéressé par un
quelconque dialogue sur un pied
d'égalité vif ou par un quelconque
travail en commun et aux costa aux
mercenaires au bout de nos peines
si tel est le cas nous ne voyons
évidemment pas l'utilité de continuer à
prétendre qu'un changement est possible
à l'avenir car l'otan a en réalité déjà
déclaré qu'un tel changement était
impossible
rouge à
zéro
les relations entre moscou et l'alliance
n'ont cessé de se détériorer depuis le
rattachement de la crimée à la russie et
sony ainsi pas la première fois que
l'organisation militaire retire des
accréditations de la russie en 2018 par
exemple sept membres de la mission russe
avait été expulsé de belgique après
l'empoisonnement de sergueï skripal un
ancien agent double russe et de sa fille
au royaume uni le nombre des
accréditations de la mission russe
auprès de l'alliance avaient alors été
réduit de 30 à 20 h la suspension des
missions de la russie et de l'otan
signifie que désormais l'alliance devra
se tourner vers l'ambassadeur russe à
bruxelles lorsqu'elle devra contacter
moscou pour le chef de la diplomatie
russe ce n'est pas la fédération de
russie qui est à l'origine de la
dégradation de ses relations mais bien
l'organisation militaire et c'est donc à
elle de faire le premier pas pour
normaliser cette situation